la quête de la perfection en toute chose
[Musique]
laurent sorriaux il a plus haut gradé
féminine de pseudo hors du japon
elles pratiquent cet art depuis une
quarantaine d'années et comme tous les
passionnés de kyudo expression japonaise
dont la traduction littérale et la voix
de l'arc
elle découvre chaque jour que son chemin
vers la perfection technique est
toujours aussi long il n'y a pas de fin
à la progression et le but c'est dit-on
le chemin c'est à dire le fait de
s'améliorer sans cesse et sans cesse et
comme nous bougeons nous changeons sans
cesse même nos cellules vieillissent
notre corps n'est pas aussi performant
que dix ans auparavant
c'est chaque fois un défi de continuer à
être à son optimum à chaque instant
[Musique]
la coupe d'europe de kyudo est organisé
tous les deux ans avec un concours
individuel et une compétition par équipe
la france et le précédent détenteur du
trophée européen par équipes dans
laquelle on ne trouve aucun pratiquants
du centre val de loire
au plan régional cette discipline reste
confidentiel centre val de loire il
existe deux clubs le club de gien à peu
près 12 13 personnes et le club de
bourges avec à peu près le même effectif
est ce que je trouve intéressant dans le
cube d'eau c'est qu'on a à la fois un
chemin personnel et précises vis-à-vis
de la technique et en même temps comme
on pratique toujours avec d'autres et
que l'harmonie de ce groupe est
fondamentale on a aussi ce travail sur
soi à faire qui est train de rencontre
le groupe restait extrêmement attentif à
l'harmonie du groupe et en étant
extrêmement juste vrai dans cette
attention aux autres
aujourd'hui la france compte une
soixantaine de clubs 800 licenciés au
total dont 45 % de femmes
[Applaudissements]